I believe that from developers, we can
expect them to have a great comprehension capacity
and of the problems of each of
our societies
and that they put that Latin spice
to find a solution
with, probably, the smallest number of
tools and resources available
I think that our main aspiration is that
they [developers] dare to think outside the box
without capitulating on the focus and vision
to solve incredibly complex problems
such as mobility or waste treatment
Tools such as Google Maps or the Cloud Platform
other tools as the hundreds of APIs
that run on the Google infrastructure. Are absolutely
essential for those entrepreneurs that just start
they gave us the platform, to not have to
worry about the things that we have to worry about in the past
probably 10 to 15 years ago, now they are solved
We can mount our talents on top of those platforms
And let imagination run
I believe that the biggest challenge, for participants
and the teams in general
will be that capacity to assemble in just a few hours
and run behind the same objective